hey guys I had a recent question related
to monk fruit and stevia and riether
tall and xylitol which one's the best
which ones there were so let's just talk
about these four sweeteners monk fruit
and stevia and recruit all all have a
zero glycemic index so they will not
increase insulin okay
xylitol on the glycemic index is thirty
so it's low but it's still a little
spike if you consume this one in small
amounts it should not be a problem now I
do use xylitol for a lot of different
recipes simply because it really tastes
just like sugar okay
stevia has a little bit of an aftertaste
but this is really good in things like
like flavoring water and carbonated
water to make like a soda and it's good
in certain recipes monk fruit also has a
slight little aftertaste it's really
really sweet so you don't need much of
it but both of these are very similar
there they kind of give a little bit of
an aftertaste they don't really taste a
hundred percent like sugar but they're
good in certain recipes but not in
others I don't really use this one as
much I use stevia a little bit more now
riether tall doesn't have the aftertaste
but it definitely does not taste like
xylitol it has more of a cold taste a
cold sweet taste but I still use this in
recipes because it's great to combine
this maybe with this or these two
together and to have the the right
balance now the other point about the
wreath throat roll is sometimes it's
made from corn which is GMO so you want
to make sure this one is non-gmo okay
same thing with xylitol this you want
this from birch bark and non-gmo and if
you're actually chewing gum
make sure it's xylitol gum and don't
worry about it interfering with your
intermittent fasting it's not going to
bump you out of ketosis it's such a
small amount that gum that you don't
want to consume is the gum with
aspartame you want to avoid these
artificial sweeteners these are sugar
alcohols and this is a fruit and this is
from a plant
these are totally fine there's a lot of
other sugar alcohols and natural
sweeteners that you can do but these are
the common ones right here between these
two I found this one tends to give
people a little more digestive problem
it consumed in larger amounts this one
can be as well but if you're having
small amounts it doesn't seem to be a
problem but when you start making these
keto bombs or these recipes but it just
tastes so good you want to eat a lot of
it well then you'll start getting some
problems because they can act as a
laxative or give you gas and sometimes
you'll hear this idea that if you
consume anything sweet whether it's monk
fruit or stevia even know it's zero
calories it's still gonna spike insulin
i've never had a problem with that i
never see a problem with that i wouldn't
worry about it thanks for watching hey I
appreciate your attention and if you're
enjoying these videos go ahead and
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated on future events live events and
webinars that we're going to do very
soon